Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Cette semaine, une émission que je prépare depuis des mois.
Je suis allé à Mons, en province de Hainaut, en Wallonie. Je suis sorti de la capitale, j'ai pris le train et tout, juste pour vous, rendez-vous compte.
Tout ça pour me rendre au SUSA. Le SUSA, c'est le Service Universitaire Spécialisé pour Personnes atteintes d'autisme. That's right.
Cette semaine, on va parler de santé mentale. J'ai interviewé pour vous les professeurs Eric Willaye et Ghislain Magerotte, qui sont tous les deux de grandes références belges dans le domaine de l'autisme.
Ghislain Magerotte est même chevalier de la Légion d'honneur pour ses travaux. Et ouais. Mais avant de se lancer dans l'interview, j'ai enregistré pour vous une belle et longue introduction qui va vous expliquer ce que c'est, en fait, l'autisme.
On écoute ça et puis on passe septante minutes avec ces messieurs. Let's go. Dans la bouche de certains, autiste, c'est d'abord une injure.
Il n'est pas rare de trouver dans le grand livre des insultes des termes qui viennent du registre médical comme schizo, handicapé, trisomique ou en l'occurrence, autiste.
À titre d'exemple, des politiciens français comme François Fillon, Jean-Louis Borloo, DSK, Ségolène Royal, José Bové et plus récemment Christophe Castaner ont tous,
à un moment ou à un autre, utilisé le terme autiste pour discréditer leurs adversaires.
Et c'est vraiment pas étonnant. Utiliser le handicap comme une insulte,
ça revient en fait à classer son adversaire comme quelqu'un d'inférieur, quelqu'un qui n'est pas à la hauteur et qui ne peut tout simplement pas revendiquer le droit d'être considéré avec dignité.
Porter sur le caractère même du président. C'était pour écarter cela qu'il a dit— Mais est-ce que vous pensez que le président de la République est autiste et n'entend pas celles et ceux qui le critiquent aujourd'hui ?
Pardon, pas autiste, mais n'entend pas. Prendre des initiatives pour rassembler ma famille, parce que c'est là où je vous dis que je ne suis pas évidemment autiste.
Par exemple, cercler comment ? Je sais que pour gagner, il faut que je rassemble ma famille. Alors mon intention n'est pas de faire tout un plaidoyer au sujet de l'handiphobie dans notre société, mais voilà,
poser le contexte me paraît important parce que de fait,
la très grande majorité des gens, y compris les politiciens que j'ai cités, ne savent pas ce qu'est l'autisme et considèrent le terme comme étant tout simplement une injure parmi d'autres.
Et le but de cette intro, c'est ça. C'est de vous expliquer de manière posée, de manière accessible, ce que c'est ce fameux trouble autistique, afin que vous soyez prêts à écouter l'interview qui va suivre.
J'ai fait beaucoup de recherches et au terme de ce podcast, on aura déconstruit pas mal d'idées reçues, en tout cas, j'espère, et on aura levé le voile sur la condition autistique, sur ce que ça implique,
qui ça concerne et surtout, mais le fait que c'est pas aussi effrayant que ce qu'on pense.
La plupart des personnes Asperger que je connais et moi y compris, rien que le fait d'entamer une conversation, ça pose déjà problème.
De quelle manière on va aborder l'autre ? Qu'est-ce qu'on va lui dire ? Comment on va enchaîner par rapport à ce qu'il va nous répondre ?
C'est tout un système de communication qui n'est pas du tout inné.
Une femme autiste sur neuf garçons autistes, peut-être c'est totalement faux et que ça se trouve dans quelques années, on se rendra compte que c'est une femme autiste pour un homme autiste.
C'est juste qu'on n'arrive pas à les détecter et à les diagnostiquer. We often grow up not knowing how to interact with others socially.
And because of that, we often end up being seen as the weird kids. And that's not necessarily because we want to be weird, it's because we don't know how to act normal.
C'est tellement rempli de codes, de sous-entendus, d'implicites, de règles à respecter, de trucs à pas faire qu'on sait pas faire.
On est très à côté du sujet. On parle souvent, on dit souvent que c'est un handicap, mais quand je suis dans ma chambre, je suis pas handicapée, moi.
Alors au fond, c'est quoi l'autisme ? L'autisme, c'est d'abord un trouble du développement qui rend les interactions sociales et la communication compliquées.
C'est une difficulté à comprendre les autres et à se mettre à leur place. C'est une difficulté à comprendre et à employer la communication non verbale.
C'est avoir du mal à comprendre les émotions et à les exprimer. Ça peut typiquement se concrétiser en une difficulté à maintenir le contact oculaire ou à comprendre les expressions du visage.
Je dis ça peut parce que l'autisme, c'est complexe. Il n'y a pas une liste de symptômes qu'on va retrouver chez tous les patients et ça va se concrétiser différemment selon la personne et selon l'intensité du trouble autistique.
De manière générale, en raison de toutes les difficultés que j'ai citées, l'autisme est souvent un obstacle pour former et pour maintenir des relations amicales ou amoureuses.
Ça peut aller de la personne qui n'éprouve aucun intérêt pour les autres à la personne qui veut absolument avoir des amis, mais qui ne sait pas comment on fait.
Les personnes qui n'ont pas d'autisme, on les appelle les neurotypiques. Par exemple, quand on est neurotypique, on est programmé biologiquement pour être attiré par les visages.
Les autistes, par contre, ne peuvent pas en dire autant. Une autre caractéristique qu'on peut parfois observer, c'est l'obsession pour la routine, pour la répétition.
Ça peut se passer au niveau corporel avec un mouvement répétitif, le fait de se balancer d'avant en arrière sans arrêt, de tourner sur soi-même, de secouer les bras,
mais ça peut aussi se concrétiser en une obsession pour la consistance et une résistance excessive au changement.
On peut par exemple imaginer une personne qui ne voudra jamais manger que des tartines à la confiture
et rien d'autre. Et cette résistance au changement, cette obsession pour la routine, il n'est pas impossible que ce soit en fait un mécanisme de défense pour se protéger de l'angoisse que peuvent provoquer les situations inconnues.
Enfin, un autre symptôme classique, c'est ce qu'on appelle les intérêts spécifiques. Un jeune garçon autiste va s'intéresser aux dinosaures, comme beaucoup d'autres enfants, mais lui, il voudra savoir absolument tout sur les dinosaures.
Connaître toutes les espèces, leurs spécificités, leurs habitudes alimentaires, leurs ossatures. Bref, tout. L'intensité sera beaucoup plus extrême que ce qu'on a l'habitude de voir.
Il ne sera en fait intéressé que par ça.
Encore une fois, il est assez probable que cet intérêt spécifique, cette obsession pour un domaine particulier, soit en réalité une façon
pour la personne de se replier sur elle-même et de faire l'autruche pour, d'une certaine manière, se préserver du monde extérieur qui est effrayant et anxiogène.
De façon générale, toutes les personnes autistes adorent s'échapper dans leur imagination. Enfin, un troisième symptôme qu'on observe chez certaines personnes qui ont de l'autisme, c'est l'hypersensibilité sensorielle.
Il y aura certains sons, certaines images, certaines textures que la personne va simplement trouver insupportables. C'est important de comprendre que l'autisme, c'est avant tout un spectre.
Je vous ai cité une série de symptômes. Il est tout à fait possible qu'une personne autiste ne soit pas du tout concernée par l'hypersensibilité, par les intérêts spécifiques ou par la nécessité d'avoir une routine.
Et de même, une autre personne pourra réunir tous ces symptômes. Chaque personne est différente. Ce qui ne change jamais, c'est la définition que j'ai donnée au début.
Une difficulté avec les interactions sociales et avec la communication. J'aime beaucoup cette définition du professeur Tony Attwood.
Les personnes qui sont sur le spectre autistique sont les personnes qui, dans la vie, ont trouvé quelque chose de plus intéressant que de socialiser.
L'autisme, c'est pas une maladie. On ne souffre pas de l'autisme comme on souffre d'une dépression ou d'un cancer. Mais on peut en revanche souffrir de ses conséquences.
L'autisme, c'est plutôt une différence. Dans la vie, il y a des grands et il y a des petits. Il y a des gros et il y a des minces.
Il y a des personnes neurotypiques et des personnes autistes. Je le disais il y a un instant, l'autisme peut prendre des formes assez différentes d'une personne à une autre.
Les psychiatres mesurent aujourd'hui l'autisme sur trois niveaux d'intensité. Quand on parle des niveaux deux et trois, on pense à des personnes qui ont clairement un besoin important d'assistance.
Ils auront un très grand mal à communiquer, à s'adapter aux situations inconnues et à vivre par eux-mêmes.
En revanche, quand il s'agit des personnes avec un autisme de niveau un, sans déficience intellectuelle ou linguistique, qu'on appelle aussi les autistes Asperger ou Aspie,
ces personnes-là n'ont aucun problème pour faire leurs courses, pour s'occuper d'elles-mêmes, pour travailler ou pour voyager.
Mais dans tous les cas, la définition de base reste valable. Autrement dit, les autistes Asperger ont des difficultés pour comprendre les autres et pour communiquer.
Et comme ça se concrétise chez eux de manière assez subtile, un Aspie sera toujours diagnostiqué bien plus tard qu'un autiste classique, voire jamais.
Et c'est justement sur l'autisme Asperger qu'on va se concentrer aujourd'hui. Je le disais, lire un visage, se faire des amis, comprendre les choses du point de vue de quelqu'un d'autre, ce sont des choses qui sont innées pour les neurotypiques.
Quand on parle des autistes Asperger, eux aussi, ils adorent se faire des amis, évidemment. Mais la différence, c'est que tout ça n'est pas inné pour eux.
C'est pas intuitif, c'est réfléchi, c'est calculé. Se faire un ami, ça se fait par intellect et pas par intuition. Et du coup, c'est compliqué, c'est fatiguant et surtout, c'est stressant.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de repérer un Aspie dans la nature. Parce que comme le caméléon, il va se camoufler.
Il va apprendre les aptitudes nécessaires pour vivre en société, même si ce n'est pas du tout intuitif pour lui.
Il ne le fera pas pour tromper ou pour jouer avec les neurotypiques, mais simplement pour survivre dans un monde qui ne lui est pas adapté.
Et ça, ça a énormément d'implications. Ça implique qu'il y a de nombreux autistes Asperger qui ont appris à se camoufler et qui s'ignorent sans doute.
Ça veut dire que quand on dit qu'il y a entre zéro virgule six et un virgule cinq pour cent de personnes qui sont sur le spectre, si ça se trouve, c'est beaucoup plus que ça.
Autrement dit, ces estimations, ça ne vaut pas grand-chose. Et surtout, ça veut dire que nos outils de diagnostic n'ont pas été à la hauteur pendant longtemps.
Et ça, ça nous amène à un point important dont on va parler aujourd'hui, à savoir l'autisme chez les femmes.
Je regardais vraiment mes petits camarades en me disant : Mon Dieu, qu'est-ce qu'ils sont bizarres.
Et alors, j'ai passé énormément de temps comme une petite anthropologue à essayer de comprendre comment ça fonctionnait les relations entre les uns et les autres, à essayer d'imiter la fameuse technique du caméléon.
J'imitais les personnes qu'il fallait. Il y avait une personne dans ma classe, par exemple, qui était populaire. Oui, il fallait imiter, répéter les choses.
C'est de la répétition en fait.
J'ai vu beaucoup de psychologues, de psychiatres, de médecins en tout genre, etc.
Et aucun n'a réussi à mettre le doigt sur mes difficultés et à poser un mot sur ma différence, simplement parce qu'en France, l'autisme est très mal connu
et le syndrome d'Asperger encore plus, surtout lorsqu'il s'agit des femmes, puisque leur autisme s'exprime de façon beaucoup plus subtile.
Quand je lui ai dit : Ça pourrait être le syndrome d'Asperger et que j'étais pas encore diagnostiquée, elle m'a fait : Je ne pense pas.
Je pense que tu es juste un petit peu asociale. Quand on imagine un enfant autiste, on visualise généralement un jeune garçon.
Pendant longtemps, on a dit que l'autisme était majoritairement un phénomène mâle et qu'il y avait entre quatre et neuf fois plus d'hommes concernés que de femmes.
D'ailleurs, encore aujourd'hui, cette question est très controversée dans la communauté scientifique. Pourquoi est-ce que je dis ça ?
J'évoquais le fait qu'il est possible de passer à travers les mailles du filet et de se camoufler parmi les neurotypiques.
On sait aujourd'hui que les jeunes filles Aspie font ça très bien. Elles sont excellentes. Elles sont très malignes et très astucieuses pour comprendre ce qui est attendu d'elles et pour s'y conformer.
Autrement dit, elles se camouflent. Elles portent un masque et elles socialisent par intellect et pas par intuition.
Mais évidemment, c'est épuisant de faire ça toute la journée, de ne jamais pouvoir être soi-même et de réfléchir en permanence à comment on se comporte.
Ça peut avoir des conséquences importantes comme la dépression, notamment à l'adolescence. C'est vrai autant pour les filles que pour les garçons, mais c'est souvent à cette période qu'on remarquera enfin l'autisme chez les filles.
En fait, l'autisme entraînera souvent d'autres troubles à l'adolescence, que ce soit l'anxiété, l'instabilité émotionnelle, les troubles de l'alimentation comme l'anorexie ou le mutisme.
Et souvent, on traitera ces maladies mentales sans repérer le trouble autistique parce qu'elles se camouflent trop bien.
Comme je le disais plus tôt, on ne souffre pas de l'autisme, mais on peut souffrir de ses conséquences. Les troubles que j'ai cités en font partie.
Le harcèlement scolaire en fait partie et on est en droit de se demander si tout ça aurait pu être évité si on avait su identifier l'autisme plus tôt chez toutes ces filles.
Alors tout ça pose énormément de questions. Est-ce que les femmes sont vraiment sous-diagnostiquées ? Et si c'est le cas, comment ça se fait ?
Est-ce que les jeunes femmes sont sujettes à une pression culturelle plus forte que les garçons pour se conformer au rôle genré ?
Certainement. Est-ce que c'est la seule raison qui fait qu'elles passent inaperçues ? Tout ça reste assez mystérieux. Voilà, j'espère que ça fait pas trop d'informations d'un seul coup.
J'estimais que c'était important de poser les bases avant de se lancer dans l'interview. Je tiens à faire une précision.
À ce stade, maintenant que vous avez appris plein de choses sur l'autisme, peut-être que soudainement, vous pensez comprendre des choses sur un collègue de travail, que vous vous interrogez sur un membre de votre famille ou sur vous-même.
C'est bête, mais je tiens à le préciser, si le trouble autistique vous intéresse, je vous encourage à vous informer à ce sujet, à faire des recherches et à éventuellement en parler à un professionnel.
Mais surtout, surtout, s'il vous plaît, ne vous improvisez pas expert. Une personne qui a des difficultés à socialiser n'est pas nécessairement autiste.
Il y a plein de facteurs qui peuvent affecter ça. C'est un travail d'expert. Et si vous vous mettez à diagnostiquer des gens autour de vous, vous risquez très fort de vous tromper et de faire une bêtise.
Libre à vous de vous poser des questions, mais surtout, soyez prudents. Pour ceux que ça intéresse, j'aurai des livres et un documentaire à vous recommander en fin de podcast.
À ce stade, si vous venez de découvrir l'autisme, vous vous posez sûrement de nombreuses questions. Et c'est pour cette raison qu'il est à présent l'heure de retrouver mes deux invités, les professeurs Ghislain Magerotte et Eric Willaye.
Bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, une émission un petit peu spéciale puisque nous recevons deux invités. Premièrement, Eric Willaye.
Eric Willaye, vous êtes docteur en psychologie et chargé de cours à la faculté de psychologie et des sciences de l'éducation à l'Université de Mons.
Vous êtes aussi directeur général de la Fondation SUSA. Eric Willaye, bonjour.
Oui, bonjour.
Et deuxièmement, nous avons aussi Ghislain Magerotte. Ghislain Magerotte, vous êtes le fondateur et le président d'honneur du SUSA.
Vous êtes également chevalier de la Légion d'honneur et vous êtes aujourd'hui retraité. Ghislain Magerotte, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Alors, quelques précisions avant de se plonger au cœur du sujet et de parler de l'autisme. Peut-être un mot sur vous deux.
J'aimerais vous demander à chacun, en quelques mots, ce qui vous a conduit à travailler avec les personnes avec autisme, ce qui fait que l'autisme a piqué votre intérêt, finalement.
Ghislain Magerotte, peut-être, pour commencer ?
Oui, volontiers. Mais initialement, c'est à partir d'une formation de parents d'enfants ayant une déficience intellectuelle que le département d'orthopédagogie avait organisé en 1984.
D'accord.
Formation résidentielle de parents où il y avait une maman qui avait deux enfants avec autisme. Et donc, ça s'est très bien passé.
Et puis, suite à ça, monsieur Salmon, qui était membre de l'APEPA, nous a contactés à l'Université de Mons pour dire : « Mais est-ce qu'on ne devrait pas faire quelque chose ensemble pour les parents ?
» Et c'est de là qu'a démarré notre intérêt à Eric et à moi pour l'autisme. Par quoi commencer ? Alors, on a dit : peut-être commencer par l'école, parce que l'école, c'est le révélateur un petit peu de tous les problèmes.
Et puis la scolarité est obligatoire, donc. Alors, en 85, 86, 87, on a sollicité des ministres successifs de l'Éducation pour finalement démarrer en 88 le projet dit Caroline.
Et donc, effectivement, j'ai retrouvé que dès 87, on avait organisé une formation avec Schopler, avec Mesibov, ici à l'Université de Mons, de façon à ce que les enfants et adolescents aient une meilleure scolarité.
Donc c'est quelque part une coïncidence. Vous avez rencontré une personne un jour qui vous a—
Vous savez, il n'y a pas de hasard, hein, mais effectivement, en nous intéressant au problème avec une déficience intellectuelle, il est assez logique que l'on en trouve l'un ou l'autre qui ait aussi des problèmes.
D'accord.
Et on a accepté cette maman qui avait deux enfants. Et puis donc, quand le projet Caroline a été lancé en 88, monsieur Salmon est revenu à la charge.
Il dit : « Oui, mais avant l'école et après l'école, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? » Alors effectivement, il faut commencer plus tôt et puis après.
Alors, ce qu'on a fait, c'est qu'on a introduit un dossier avec lui à l'INAMI en 89, 90, pour faire une consultation ambulatoire spécialisée en autisme.
Alors, l'INAMI nous a répondu : « C'est une très bonne idée de faire ça », mais on nous a renvoyés aux régions ou aux communautés parce qu'en plus, on était dans un mouvement de communautarisation, régionalisation.
Bienvenue en Belgique.
Et donc, on a continué grâce à une fondation, la Fondation Marguerite-Marie Delacroix, qui nous a donné le budget, je pense, pour une petite année.
Et puis alors, on a été reconnus un petit peu par la WIP en 95. Et puis, on a été reconnus un petit peu comme service d'accompagnement, mais pas comme consultation, parce que ça ne relevait pas de la WIP.
Et puis, petit à petit, pour l'aide précoce et puis pour les adultes. Et puis, c'est en 2005 que la Fondation SUSA a pu avoir la consultation pour personnes avec autisme, faire le diagnostic et assurer le premier projet d'intervention.
Et puis alors, c'est le rôle des services d'accompagnement ici à Mons ou des autres services de Belgique, de suivre les enfants.
Oui. Alors, Ghislain Magerotte a un petit peu répondu pour ce qui est de comment tout ça a démarré il y a à peu près 30 ans.
Les activités du SUSA aujourd'hui, peut-être, Eric Willaye, vous pouvez nous expliquer, que fait le SUSA, finalement, pour accompagner les personnes autistes ?
Voilà, comme Ghislain Magerotte vient de le dire, le SUSA a des activités de diagnostic, hein, auprès des enfants, des adolescents et d'une partie du public des adultes.
Il développe aussi des services d'accompagnement. Alors, des services d'accompagnement qui se situent maintenant partout en communauté française, puisqu'on est implantés à Bruxelles et à Liège également.
Avec ces activités d'accompagnement
visent à apporter un support aux personnes là où elles vivent, c'est-à-dire dans leur famille ou dans les services qu'elles fréquentent, des services scolaires ou d'autres types de services comme des services,
de la communauté habituelle, des troupes scouts ou d'autres environnements dans lesquels les personnes avec autisme peuvent vivre et avoir des activités de loisirs, par exemple.
D'autre part, la Fondation SUSA développe des activités d'accueil pour des adultes qui ont de l'autisme. Donc, on a un service d'activité de jour qui se trouve à Dour et un logement pour quatre personnes qui ont de l'autisme.
La Fondation SUSA a développé historiquement des activités de répit dépannage. Donc, on a une organisation qui se trouve à Gembloux,
qui est une maison d'accueil temporaire pour des enfants, des adolescents ou des adultes où,
les parents peuvent trouver une ressource de, voilà, de répit, hein, de relais lorsque, voilà, ils sont en difficulté avec leur enfant, leur adolescent ou leur adulte, puisqu'à l'heure actuelle,
encore de nombreux adultes sont à la maison 24 heures sur 24
et que donc les familles ont grand besoin, effectivement, d'avoir des solutions de ressource.
Alors d'autre part, la Fondation SUSA a aussi une mission de formation, hein, qu'elle assume auprès des professionnels en Belgique et à l'étranger,
que ce soit des professionnels du monde de l'enseignement ou des professionnels du monde de l'action sociale.
D'autre part, la fondation a également mission de recherche. Et donc,
là, tout prochainement, nous développerons une recherche qui concernera la guidance parentale des parents d'enfants de très jeune âge,
pour effectivement favoriser le développement dès que possible de ces enfants qui sont identifiés comme ayant des problématiques spécifiques.
Et en plus, en tant que chargé de cours ici à Mons, tu as une responsabilité de formation des psychologues.
Oui, à l'Université de Mons, oui. Très bien. Ben donc, ça fait de nombreuses choses qui ont été évoquées. On reviendra au moins sur le diagnostic, puisqu'il y a beaucoup de choses à dire là-dessus, je pense.
Ghislain Magerotte, on vous décrit souvent comme un pionnier dans le traitement de l'autisme. On le disait, vous avez fondé le SUSA il y a une trentaine d'années à peu près.
Vous avez reçu il y a quelque temps l'insigne de Chevalier de la Légion d'honneur. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu, nous raconter comment c'est arrivé et pour quelles raisons ça a eu lieu ?
Je ne sais pas très bien comment c'est arrivé, mais c'est effectivement les activités, les contacts que l'on avait avec la France qui ont, je pense, déterminé un petit peu ce type de distinction honorifique.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas en partie lié à la situation en France qui est, on va dire, qui est loin d'être idéale ?
J'ai par exemple pu entendre que les personnes avec autisme étaient traitées comme des malades mentaux et qu'elles étaient gardées dans les hôpitaux de jour en France.
Oui, mais ça, c'est tout à fait l'histoire de la France hein.
Oui.
Les hôpitaux de jour ont joué un rôle très important depuis, je pense, le milieu des années Septante, je pense.
Et c'est vrai que pour les Belges, c'était un petit peu paradoxal d'aller en hôpital, fût-ce hôpital de jour. Et c'est vrai.
Alors, mes contacts avec la France, c'était lors de conférences ou d'activités où je faisais la promotion d'approches éducatives ou psychoéducatives.
Et c'est vrai qu'au début, quand on a commencé à parler de Teach, les Français aussi se sont un peu réveillés et ont aussi développé l'approche Teach en France.
Et donc c'est probablement un petit peu par les contacts que j'avais là avec des parents ou des associations de parents que j'ai été davantage connu en France.
Et j'avais entendu parler aussi de nombreux enfants qui venaient de la France pour venir—
Ça, ça, c'est une autre histoire, ça hein.
Ça n'a pas de rapport avec, ça n'a pas de rapport avec vous, avec—
Ah non, moi, je ne les ai pas attirés. Je ne les ai pas attirés en Belgique parce que je pense qu'au Susa, nous avons certainement une philosophie qui est de dire qu'il ne faut pas couper les enfants de leur milieu de vie familial, scolaire, de leurs relations.
Et donc, manifestement, 'fin, j'allais là avec l'idée que la France développe un petit peu d'autres types de services.
À l'école, par exemple hein, l'école doit aussi beaucoup se modifier en France, mais aussi des services, disons, du médico-social.
Rapidement, j'avais évoqué cette histoire d'enfants français qui venaient en grand nombre en Belgique. À quoi c'était dû ?
Comment est-ce qu'on explique ça ?
Ah ben, je pense qu'ils sont venus en Belgique parce qu'il n'y avait pas de place en France, pas de place pour eux.
Oui, pas de—
Parce qu'il y en a qui—
rien n'était accommodé.
Parce qu'il y en a qui viennent en Belgique à l'école.
C'est effectivement une grande différence entre la Belgique et la France. C'est vrai que
on targue peut-être l'enseignement spécialisé dans la partie francophone de toutes les tares, les tares du monde, mais
il a le mérite d'exister et d'offrir une scolarité à des enfants qui présentent tout type de déficience et que cet enseignement spécialisé est absent en France.
D'accord.
Il n'y a pas d'enseignement spécialisé.
Encore aujourd'hui.
Ah oui, oui, tout à fait. Et donc, je pense que cette offre de services qu'a la Belgique
et la Communauté française par rapport à ces enfants qui présentent des handicaps divers, est une offre de services inexistante en France, avec une scolarité possible à temps plein, alors qu'en France, évidemment,
on a promu l'inclusion scolaire, mais l'inclusion scolaire, elle a lieu parfois pour certains enfants une à deux heures par semaine.
Mais que font les enfants toutes les autres heures de la semaine ? Et donc des parents viennent chercher des solutions scolaires.
Des parents viennent de très, très loin. Des enfants viennent de très, très loin. Et les parents également, pour amener leurs enfants.
Certains enfants viennent de la région parisienne, de la région de Lyon.
Oui.
Et sont hébergés ici à un très jeune âge, parfois, en deçà de six ans. On peut quand même se poser beaucoup de questions sur l'intérêt global qu'il y a à être déraciné sitôt de son environnement familial.
Il faudrait vraiment que l'enseignement qu'on propose ici soit d'une qualité tellement inestimable que ce soit le cas.
Mais je pense que quand on est parent et que l'on cherche des solutions, ben, on est prêt à prendre évidemment des solutions qui paraissent, je pense, à l'évidence, probablement très insatisfaisantes.
Mais quand il y a que cette solution-là, pour parfois pouvoir aussi continuer à travailler et s'occuper des autres enfants de la famille.
Mais a priori, à l'heure actuelle, il y a globalement peu d'enfants non scolarisés en Belgique hein. Il ne reste plus que quelques établissements pour personnes non scolarisées, alors qu'en France, c'est plutôt la situation.
C'est plutôt la norme, oui.
La situation de la France, évidemment. D'avoir une population, je pense, quatre fois plus importante que la Belgique, je pense, quatre à cinq fois plus importante.
Mais ça veut donc dire que répondre à l'entièreté des besoins est quelque chose de
d'assez, d'assez énorme. Et donc, effectivement, en termes qualitatifs, il y a maintenant en France pas mal d'établissements qui se créent, qui sont de très bonne qualité, d'aussi bonne qualité que ce qui se fait ici en Belgique.
Mais par contre, la réponse à la quantité de besoins est vraiment... Il y a un retard énorme dans leur pays, ce qui veut dire qu'effectivement, des personnes continuent à chercher des solutions en Belgique.
Alors, un mot maintenant sur le vocabulaire, l'emploi de la langue française, puisque j'ai remarqué un glissement que j'ai fait tout à l'heure.
J'ai dit : « Personne autiste », alors que vous conseillez plutôt de parler de « personne avec autisme ». Est-ce que vous pouvez nous mettre à niveau à ce sujet-là et nous expliquer un petit peu ?
Si je vous dis personne autiste. Personne autiste. Qu'est-ce qui vous vient à l'esprit ? C'est autiste qui vient. Quand on dit personne avec autisme, là, on distingue les deux choses.
On peut être très beau, c'est une qualité, et avoir de l'autisme. Donc, je pense que quand on dit c'est un autiste ou c'est une personne autiste, quand on a ajouté le mot personne, il y avait déjà du progrès.
Mais habituellement, on disait : « C'est un autiste ». On ne voyait que ça. Et donc, on a essayé d'introduire cette formulation ici dans le vocabulaire français.
Et habituellement, on dit un enfant avec autisme ou bien il a de l'autisme ou il présente. Enfin, voilà.
Oui, est-ce qu'il y a un consensus là-dessus ? Est-ce que tout le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il faut dire—
Non, non.
Personne avec autisme ? En faisant des recherches, moi, j'ai entendu des personnes qui étaient directement concernées, qui étaient des autistes Asperger, et qui disaient personne autiste plutôt que de dire personne avec autisme.
Oui, tout le monde n'est pas d'accord. Et notamment les personnes qui ont le syndrome d'Asperger, disons, se présentent un peu comme des personnes un peu à part.
D'accord. Toutes les personnes autistes, finalement. Les personnes avec autisme.
Qui, qui, qui n'est pas à part ?
Oui, c'est ça, voilà.
Qui n'est pas à part ? Et donc, on parle maintenant de la, comment est-ce qu'on dit ? De la neurodiversité.
Uhuh.
Bah, c'est vrai que nous sommes tous les trois très différents, hein. Mais c'est vrai que lorsque l'on a certaines caractéristiques, on est manifestement beaucoup plus différents que d'autres.
Yes. Alors, je vais faire un effort géant pour essayer de dire personne avec autisme. Il est possible que je glisse de temps en temps et que je fasse l'une ou l'autre bévue.
Mais c'est la personne.
Oui, ça, c'est sûr, oui.
C'est l'enfant qui compte. Il a de l'autisme, mais il peut avoir aussi d'autres qualités ou d'autres défauts, enfin.
En préparant cette émission, j'ai beaucoup lu et j'ai parfois pu lire des choses assez contradictoires, je le disais, et notamment en ce qui concerne le rapport entre autisme et empathie.
J'ai tantôt lu que les personnes avec autisme avaient un défaut d'empathie et tantôt qu'au contraire, elles étaient vraiment hypersensibles aux émotions des autres.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'il en est finalement ? Quel est le lien entre autisme et empathie ?
Alors, peut-être pour aborder cette question, cette question qui n'est pas aisée, comme beaucoup de choses dans le domaine de l'autisme.
Parce que lorsqu'on parle d'autisme, on ne parle pas d'une entité, d'une entité unique.
On parle d'un spectre. Et ce spectre fait apparaître que des personnes peuvent avoir, pour certaines, partie des capacités et pour d'autres, avoir de grandes déficiences dans ces capacités.
Mais que souvent, encore
à l'heure actuelle, la façon dont on aborde cette problématique de
de capacité chez les personnes avec autisme est abordée au travers de personnes dont les compétences fonctionnelles ou les compétences intellectuelles sont d'assez bon niveau, les compétences communicationnelles sont de bon niveau.
Mais est-ce que ces capacités qui sont évaluées au travers de ce sous-groupe sont à l'image de ce que sont les capacités des autres ?
Et ça, c'est un problème au niveau de la recherche à l'heure actuelle, parce qu'effectivement, il n'y a pas du tout de réponse à ça.
Alors, la question de l'empathie, il faut la rapporter probablement à la problématique de la théorie de l'esprit, c'est-à-dire la capacité que nous avons à
pouvoir imaginer, pouvoir penser que quelqu'un d'autre vit ou non les mêmes choses que nous au même moment où nous les vivons.
Est-ce qu'il éprouve les mêmes sentiments, les mêmes émotions, les mêmes sensations que nous lorsque nous vivons une situation ?
Ben, ce que l'on semble démontrer, c'est que pas mal de personnes avec autisme, je dis pas mal et donc je ne dis pas toutes nécessairement, pas mal de personnes avec autisme ont d'énormes problèmes dans cette théorie de l'esprit.
Ce que d'ailleurs les jeunes enfants en dessous de cinq ans n'ont pas non plus, hein. Donc, on a parlé durant longtemps, lorsqu'on parlait d'autisme, d'un trouble envahissant du développement.
Et je pense que c'est effectivement aussi cette problématique-là, c'est que l'autisme, c'est un problème de développement
et que certaines personnes avec autisme vont bien se développer et que d'autres personnes avec autisme vont moins bien se développer.
Et que, ben, quand on parlait de troubles envahissants du développement, on soulignait l'idée que toutes les sphères fonctionnelles de la personne étaient atteintes,
hein, que ce soit la sphère intellectuelle, la sphère communicative, la sphère sensorielle.
Peut-être qu'on a perdu un petit peu de cet aspect-là avec trouble du spectre de l'autisme, comme on en a parlé, mais je pense que ça exprime bien le fait que
avoir de l'autisme, c'est être impacté dans toutes les facettes de son fonctionnement et en particulier la question de l'empathie.
C'est pouvoir considérer que quelqu'un d'autre n'éprouve pas les mêmes choses que soi, mais pouvoir aussi avoir une préoccupation positive pour autrui.
Il faut faire le constat que les personnes avec autisme, pour bonne part d'entre elles, ont une forme d'égocentrisme par rapport à leur vision du monde, hein, et que
cette vision du monde égocentrique n'est pas une volonté de ne pas connaître l'autre ou de ne pas être intéressé par l'autre.
C'est une difficulté fondamentale et beaucoup de personnes avec autisme font des efforts énormes pour comprendre leur environnement social, pour comprendre.
Mais cette forme d'intuition sociale leur est complexe à acquérir.
Pour prendre un exemple simple, si je comprends bien, si une personne avec autisme croise quelqu'un dans la rue qui pleure, elle ne sera pas désintéressée, elle n'en aura pas rien à faire de voir cette personne en pleurs,
mais elle aura, si je comprends bien, une difficulté à comprendre ce qui se passe dans sa tête et à se mettre à sa place.
Difficulté à comprendre, mais aussi à l'exprimer.
Oui, c'est ça, oui.
Je pense que ces difficultés que vous décrivez, faire le constat que quelqu'un pleure et qu'intellectuellement, que quelqu'un pleure, ça doit être qu'il est triste, mais il est triste pourquoi ?
Et c'est quoi l'émotion que l'on ressent quand on est triste ? Ben, je pense que tous ces facteurs-là, alors empathie, émotion,
signification, c'est très interrelié et que les personnes avec autisme ont beaucoup de difficultés à faire : est-ce qu'il pleure parce que c'est l'environnement dans lequel il se trouve qui le fait pleurer ?
Ou est-ce qu'il pleure parce qu'il pense à quelque chose qui le rend triste ? Ou est-ce qu'il vient de vivre un événement qui l'a rendu triste ?
Si c'est un événement qui traite des relations entre les gens, ben, on lui a dit quelque chose qui était désagréable.
Voilà, il vient s'entendre critiquer pour sa façon d'être, sa façon... C'est tout ça qui est complexe pour les personnes avec autisme.
Pouvoir imaginer pourquoi quelqu'un d'autre vit ces émotions-là est vraiment quelque chose de difficile à aborder. Quand on a des déficiences plus importantes.
Et ça, ça s'exprime quand on voit ces enfants dans les cours de récréation. Quand on a une théorie de l'esprit déficitaire, quand on donne un coup de pied à quelqu'un, on a peu de capacité à pouvoir se dire qu'on lui a fait du mal.
Et que donc, c'est bien souvent la réaction, la mimique que va voir l'autre ou la réaction qui va impacter la façon dont la personne avec autisme va interpréter la situation.
Et on voit des enfants avec autisme qui pincent, qui mordent, qui frappent, qui tirent les cheveux, pas pour provoquer une émotion négative, mais simplement parce qu'ils ont constaté que la personne réagit.
Quand vous donnez ces exemples-là et que vous parlez d'un jeune enfant qui ne comprend pas très bien que, voilà, que donner un coup de pied, ça génère de la douleur ou qui a énormément de difficultés à mettre en lien
l'émotion, la cause de l'émotion, le, voilà, le ressenti de l'autre personne.
Je me trompe peut-être, mais j'ai le sentiment qu'on parle à ce moment-là plutôt de personnes avec un autisme
plus sévère, on va dire de niveau deux ou trois, mais j'ai le sentiment que ça ne ressemble pas tellement à l'autisme Asperger qu'on évoquait plus tôt. C'est juste ?
C'est une question extrêmement complexe. À partir du moment où une personne présente les mêmes capacités que tout un chacun dans ses relations sociales, ben on ne parle plus d'autisme.
Je ne sais pas si je me fais bien comprendre, mais ça veut dire que l'autisme, il est caractérisé par des difficultés fondamentales dans la communication sociale et dans les interactions sociales.
Ça veut donc dire que l'on décrit dans la façon de comprendre et de s'exprimer un ensemble de particularités qui sont suffisamment importantes.
C'est peut-être ça aussi qu'il faut souligner. C'est suffisamment important pour se distinguer d'un fonctionnement social dit ordinaire.
Et quand on parle d'ordinaire ou de norme, la norme, c'est large, ce n'est pas qu'une façon d'être. Et donc, c'est-à-dire que la norme, elle est large.
Il y a des gens qui sont très communicants, d'autres qui le sont moins, des gens qui sont très relationnels, des gens qui le sont moins.
Donc la norme, c'est aussi un spectre. La norme, c'est un spectre. Ça veut dire que ceux qui présentent un trouble du spectre de l'autisme sortent d'une forme de norme dans les relations sociales et dans la communication sociale.
Donc ça veut dire que c'est quand même particulier. Ce n'est pas simplement une difficulté à vivre son quotidien dans des relations avec autrui.
C'est très particulier, ça met les gens en grande difficulté. Alors, on dit : ben les personnes avec un syndrome d'Asperger ont des difficultés, mais il faut dire que ce sont des difficultés sévères.
Ce ne sont pas des difficultés légères. Pour sortir d'un spectre de la normalité, il faut que ce soit des problématiques qui impactent quand même votre vie.
Alors là où évidemment, on a beaucoup de difficultés parfois à cerner les choses, c'est que lorsqu'on a un bon potentiel intellectuel, c'est une force.
Ça veut dire que vos capacités intellectuelles vous permettent parfois,
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs un des... 'Fin, voilà, si on pouvait dire un des avantages d'avoir ce potentiel intellectuel, de compenser les difficultés de relations sociales.
C'est-à-dire que vous apprenez, comme peut-être bien d'autres, hein. Les enfants ordinaires aussi doivent apprendre les relations sociales, hein.
Elles ne sont pas si évidentes que ça, hein. Apprendre qu'on ne frappe pas, ben, apprendre qu'on dit bonjour, ça s'apprend.
'Fin, c'est pas intuitif.
Oui.
Mais les personnes qui ont un syndrome d'Asperger ou un autisme dit de haut niveau sont capables d'apprendre. Et donc, à un moment donné, est-ce qu'il y a une
si grande différence entre le fonctionnement des personnes qui ont un trouble de spectre de la normalité faible ou un trouble de spectre de l'autisme faible ?
Oui.
Ben est-ce que ces personnes ne se rejoignent pas sur une—
Ils arrivent à vivre ensemble. Donc, c'est—
Ben je pense qu'effectivement, c'est en tout cas ce en quoi on croit, c'est que nous sommes convaincus l'un et l'autre qu'on peut amener les personnes toutes à vivre ensemble.
Et je crois que c'est l'enjeu que l'on a, enfin, ce que l'on essaie de rencontrer dans toutes les activités que l'on mène, c'est que l'on puisse vivre ensemble, mais chacun avec sa diversité, sa particularité, voire sa différence parfois.
Oui, du coup, pour rejoindre ça, j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a un petit peu deux écoles de pensée.
D'une part, celles et ceux qui sont d'avis qu'il faut essayer d'inculquer aux personnes avec autisme les codes du monde entre guillemets normal, les fondre dans le moule de la normalité entre guillemets.
Et l'autre école qui dit : mais finalement, on pourrait juste leur foutre la paix, les laisser être eux-mêmes et ne pas les obliger à se fondre dans le moule.
De quelle école faites-vous partie ?
Je pense que ça ne va pas tout seul pour personne. Chacun doit faire un effort. Effectivement, vivre avec une personne qui a de l'autisme, et notamment avec un adulte, demande des efforts de la part de l'un, mais aussi de l'autre.
Je pense que c'est une question quasi existentielle, cette question.
Oui, oui, tout à fait.
Cette question existentielle, elle n'a rien à voir avec la pratique, elle n'a rien à voir avec les techniques. Parce que si on pose cette question, posons-la pour tout le monde.
Est-ce que les enfants neurotypiques, puisqu'on utilise ce mot-là, est-ce que les enfants neurotypiques ont envie d'aller à l'école ?
Est-ce que les enfants neurotypiques ont envie d'apprendre à dire bonjour à la dame ? Est-ce que les enfants neurotypiques ont envie d'apprendre la musique ?
Je suis pas certain hein. Et donc pourquoi ceux-là les forcerait-on
au titre de leur aspect neurotypique, hein, ou de leur vie neurotypique, et que les personnes qui ont une particularité comme
celle du syndrome d'Asperger ne seraient pas amenées, pour vivre dans une société, à partager, maintenant avec effort, mais peut-être que tout le monde, enfin, fait les choses avec effort hein.
Donc, vous êtes plutôt d'avis que c'est un compromis pour les uns et pour les autres.
Mais il faut respecter la différence des gens hein. Il faut respecter leurs différences. Le propos n'est pas de dire que tout le monde doit vivre de la même façon non plus.
Voilà, vous, moi, Ghislain, on a des vies, on a des vies différentes. C'est très bien comme ça d'ailleurs.
Alors, on peut vivre de manière solitaire, on peut vivre de manière à l'abri de stimulations qui vous font, qui vous font du tort,
bien évidemment.
Ou alors, je pense qu'il faudra créer un pays pour-
L'Autistan.
Oui.
Oui, mais je pense que parfois, certains tendraient à penser que c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut faire, mais je suis très prudent par rapport à-
On entend parfois dire que si les neurotypiques, pour employer ce terme-là de nouveau, ont une compréhension innée ou
relativement innée des codes sociaux, on entend certains dire que les autistes Asperger entre eux se comprennent beaucoup mieux et que finalement, quand on ne mélange pas les deux groupes sociaux, ils fonctionnent relativement bien.
Ils se comprennent relativement bien entre eux. Est-ce que c'est vrai ça ?
Oui, encore qu'ils se comprennent entre eux, peut-être, mais voilà, nous qui travaillons quand même depuis pas mal d'années dans ce milieu, je pense qu'il y a une façon aussi de comprendre les personnes qui ont de l'autisme.
Si on veut former des professionnels à pouvoir s'occuper
d'un public qui a des particularités dans son fonctionnement sociocommunicatif, nous devons pouvoir essayer d'imaginer, parce que peut-être que nous avons nous aussi une très mauvaise théorie de l'esprit hein.
Est-ce que nous savons comment pense une personne qui a une déficience intellectuelle ? Est-ce que nous savons comment pense une personne qui a de l'autisme ?
Est-ce que je sais, moi, comment pense Ghislain Magerotte ? À force de se côtoyer, bien évidemment qu'on-
Toujours une différence de toute façon.
Mais il y a toujours une différence dans la façon dont on... Mais c'est vrai qu'on essaie à l'heure actuelle de connaître au travers de multiples recherches comment une personne avec autisme perçoit son environnement, comment
elle communique dans sa langue.
Enfin, comment elle utilise le langage, comment, quand il n'y a pas de langage, comment elle peut percevoir. Il y a beaucoup de recherches qui sont menées
pour essayer de comprendre le fonctionnement et que c'est peut-être en comprenant qu'on peut nous aussi peut-être apporter un environnement qui sera plus facile à percevoir et à comprendre.
Pour revenir sur la question, cette idée que les autistes Asperger se comprennent relativement bien entre eux, plus qu'ils ne comprennent les personnes qui ne sont pas autistes,
ça vous paraît juste ou bien est-ce que ça vous paraît fantasmé ?
Ben probablement qu'elles utilisent. Par exemple, on évoque souvent le langage assez littéral, enfin en tout cas dans l'interprétation du langage littéral.
Ben j'imagine qu'à partir du moment où on rentre dans une forme de langage qui a cet aspect littéral et où tout cet aspect du langage symbolique au second degré, etc.,
est peut-être un peu éliminé de la langue de tous les jours, je pense qu'on se comprend beaucoup mieux.
Et je crois que c'est l'effort que nous nous avons à faire, c'est que j'ai un chat dans la gorge, ben ok, c'est...
Mais voilà, c'est assez trivial d'utiliser ce genre d'exemple, mais à partir du moment où notre langue, elle est faite toujours d'images,
c'est très clair que pour les personnes qui ont de l'autisme, c'est un effort considérable de mettre les choses
en lien les unes avec les autres et de se dire : ben oui, mais ce n'est pas ça qu'il veut dire, c'est autre chose qu'il veut dire.
Ça doit être un effort permanent. Mais par contre, si on utilise un langage qui est un langage
dont on élimine toute une série de facteurs de distraction comme ceux-là, je pense qu'effectivement, c'est un effort moins important et qu'on se comprend beaucoup mieux.
Mais l'effort peut être fait par des personnes ordinaires qui vont, et c'est là tout notre travail, c'est de former des professionnels et des parents.
Et des parents, parce que ben quand on est parent d'un enfant qui a de l'autisme, on n'a pas appris comment fonctionne un enfant qui a de l'autisme.
Et quand on, enfin là, on évoquait la question des formations de parents là tout à l'heure. C'est ce que nous apprenons aux parents, c'est aussi à maîtriser leur langue pour que leurs enfants les comprennent mieux.
Vous évoquiez tout à l'heure l'idée qu'un quotient intellectuel élevé pouvait aider à compenser et peut-être à comprendre qu'il n'y a pas vraiment un chat dans la gorge et peut-être à surmonter ces obstacles-là.
En discutant avec des amis, j'ai évoqué à plusieurs reprises le fait que j'allais réaliser cette interview. Et
histoire de tâter un peu le terrain, je me suis amusé à leur demander ce qu'ils savaient de l'autisme et ça a un petit peu confirmé ce à quoi je m'attendais.
C'est-à-dire que
il y a un petit peu deux grands stéréotypes et qu'ils pensent soit à Rain Man avec une personnalité fondamentalement différente et avec une forme d'intelligence, avec des capacités hors du commun, ou bien au contraire,
ils pensent que ça fait référence à des personnes avec des déficiences intellectuelles très importantes.
Donc, il y a dans l'imaginaire collectif une certaine association entre l'autisme et le quotient intellectuel, qu'il soit relativement élevé ou bien relativement bas.
Est-ce que cette association existe vraiment ? Est-ce qu'il y a un lien de causalité entre autisme et quotient intellectuel ou bien est-ce qu'au contraire, c'est totalement fantasmé ?
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de lien entre autisme et quotient intellectuel. D'ailleurs, je ne pense pas que Rain Man était quelqu'un de très intelligent hein.
Je pense qu'on a un peu raconté ça.
Oui. Ça fait si longtemps que j'ai pas vu le film.
Oui, mais je pense qu'il n'avait manifestement pas de compétences aux tests d'intelligence qui se seraient révélées supérieures.
Rain Man, c'est presque un stéréotype de l'autisme. Je crois qu'on a eu peu d'occasions-
Ah oui.
...dans nos rencontres quand même déjà maintenant nombreuses, de rencontrer quelqu'un aussi, j'allais dire, caricatural n'est pas le bon mot, parce que c'est une description de l'autisme quasi scolaire qui était faite dans Rain Man.
Mais avec quelqu'un dont effectivement les compétences, parfois proprement quasi perceptuelles, mais à la fois cognitives, quand il sait compter le nombre, voilà, d'allumettes qui sont, enfin, ou de-
Pour aller dans ses dents là.
Oui, oui, les cure-dents, les cure-dents sont tombés. Et voilà, il dit-- Mais on voit combien dans sa compréhension sociale, dans ses compétences cognitives, il éprouve des difficultés.
Il commence à traverser la rue parce qu'il sait que le feu est vert, mais l'interprétation qu'il fait de cette règle sociale, c'est quand le feu est rouge, on ne traverse plus.
Et il s'arrête en plein milieu de la rue parce que le feu vient de se mettre rouge. Et donc, il n'y a pas d'interprétation sociale de l'apprentissage d'une règle.
Et ça, je crois que ça crée des difficultés pour les personnes qui ont-
Oui, donc il y a du juste dans ce film, mais ça reste assez stéréotypé, ça reste assez...
Bien sûr, parce qu'effectivement, la réalité clinique, ce n'est pas celle-là. Parce que les gens, voilà, ils ont des faiblesses, ils ont des forces et que les forces compensent parfois, bien évidemment, les faiblesses des uns et des autres.
Mais donc, je retiens pas de lien direct entre quotient intellectuel et autisme. Et du coup, j'ai envie de poser la question : est-ce qu'il y a un lien entre autisme et les troubles obsessionnels compulsifs, les TOC ?
Parce que voilà, j'ai pu lire qu'il y avait un pourcentage relativement élevé des personnes avec autisme qui en avaient.
À la jeune adolescence, vers dix, onze ans, on voit que certains enfants vont vers des comportements stéréotypés, obsessionnels.
Alors, est-ce qu'il s'agit-
C'est la deuxième caractéristique de l'autisme hein.
C'est quand même une caractéristique de l'autisme hein, les comportements et intérêts restreints et répétitifs. Alors, qu'est-ce qui fait la différence entre un TOC et un comportement et intérêt restreint et répétitif ?
C'est parfois très complexe à faire.
Donc peut-être, peut-être avec des faux positifs alors ?
Oui, parce que le TOC, c'est quand même une entité diagnostique. Donc est-ce que c'est la combinaison des deux ou est-ce que c'est l'expression un peu extrême d'une particularité de l'autisme ?
Enfin, on sait que les enfants qui ont de l'autisme sont des enfants très anxieux parce qu'ils comprennent mal leur environnement
et que je pense que certains vont vers des comportements répétitifs, des stéréotypies comme on dit hein, des stéréotypies pour contrôler un petit peu leur anxiété, parce que ça, ils contrôlent facilement.
Et donc on voit des enfants qui vont avoir des comportements répétitifs de se toucher les chaussures, etc., pour contrôler un petit peu l'anxiété qu'ils sont en train de vivre.
Alors, est-ce qu'on décrit là un TOC ? Je crois que là, on n'en est pas encore à ce niveau de recherche par rapport à-
D'accord. Ça reste flou.
Oui, oui, mais voilà, certains évoquent des doubles ou des triples diagnostics quand on a de l'autisme. On peut avoir de l'autisme et encore autre chose.
Ce qui, a priori, me semble relativement naturel, finalement.
Mais je retiens aussi surtout que vous disiez qu'il pouvait y avoir une ambiguïté entre l'obsession pour la routine, pour la répétitivité et, ben, les TOC.
Et donc peut-être parfois une ambiguïté où les symptômes sont un peu les mêmes.
Bien sûr qu'au niveau peut-être des symptômes, on pourrait avoir des similitudes, mais encore faut-il, est-ce que, ben, on a pris la peine de faire un diagnostic différentiel autisme et TOC ?
Je suis pas toujours certain que ce soit le cas. C'est parfois sur une impression que la vie est donnée. On dit : ça, c'est un TOC.
J'ai pu lire aussi que les personnes avec autisme avaient horreur du mensonge et qu'elles se laissaient facilement berner, qu'il y avait une grande pureté chez elles et que donc ça pouvait mener à des choses assez sombres hein.
On pense aux manipulateurs, aux pervers narcissiques, aux violences sexuelles. Déjà, est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous constatez quand vous interagissez avec des patients ?
Et ensuite, ben, comment est-ce que ça s'explique ? Parce que c'est quand même-- ça semble assez déconnecté du reste en fait.
Oui et non. Tout à l'heure, on a évoqué la question de la théorie de l'esprit. C'est tout à fait en lien avec la théorie de l'esprit.
Mentir, c'est faire croire à quelqu'un d'autre que ce n'est pas la réalité. Moi, je crois qu'avoir une bonne théorie de l'esprit, c'est aussi apprendre à mentir.
D'accord, c'est-- vous vous exprimez au nom de l'Université de Mons ?
Non, absolument pas, non, non. Mon titre personnel est suffisant
. Mon engagement n'ira que jusque-là. Je crois qu'il y a effectivement, malheureusement, une grande crédulité parfois chez les personnes qui ont de l'autisme, une confiance quasi totale dans l'autre hein.
Confiance totale dans l'autre. Et je crois que ça met parfois en évidence le fait que certains, ça donne parfois des comportements peu acceptables parce que
c'est pour eux la garantie d'être le copain d'eux si on a fait ce que le copain demandait.
Oui, donc on se laisse manipuler.
On se laisse manipuler parce que, 'fin, c'est une naïveté positive, hein.
L'autisme, ce n'est pas un handicap, mais ça peut générer des situations de handicap. C'est une nuance
importante. Je pense par exemple aux autistes Asperger qui ne peuvent pas travailler en open space, qui sont incapables de prendre des transports en commun à cause de l'hypersensibilité sensorielle.
Voilà, ça, ça les dépasse. Quand vous recevez des patients qui sont justement autistes Asperger,
typiquement dans les grandes lignes, de quoi est-ce que-- puisqu'ils ont une situation qui leur est propre, qui est différente des personnes avec un autisme plus sévère.
De quoi est-ce qu'ils vont vous parler ? De quoi vont-ils se plaindre ? Quel est le problème qu'on a quand on a un autisme relativement léger ?
Si c'est un adulte, probablement que ça sera le travail, les relations sociales.
Les relations conjugales, parfois, hein.
Oui.
Maintenant, quand ce sont des enfants, ce sont plus des problèmes scolaires. Problèmes liés parfois au fait d'être
bousculé psychologiquement par, 'fin, par les condisciples, parce qu'on est différent, on est particulier et que c'est difficile à vivre, hein.
C'est-- voilà, cette phase de l'adolescence n'est pas aisée non plus, hein, pour ces personnes qui ont un-
Si je comprends bien, ça peut être à l'école, ça peut être le monde du travail, ça peut être le relationnel...
Avec peut-être à l'âge de l'adolescence, certains enfants, 'fin, certains ados qui nous sont amenés par leurs parents ne-- refusent le diagnostic, n'acceptent pas d'être diagnostiqués.
Parce que la différence, c'est trop stigmatisant, c'est trop...
Bien évidemment, ils sont pas nécessairement demandeurs de ce diagnostic que d'autres revendiquent un outrage, hein.
Et je pense à ce moment-là aux adultes qui effectivement, pour certains, revendiquent ce diagnostic parce qu'effectivement, ils vivent une vie sociale, conjugale, professionnelle compliquée.
Et je crois que c'est surtout l'impact de l'autisme qui pose des problèmes, parfois plus que l'autisme lui-même, d'une certaine manière, hein.
Oui, pour aller vers cette question-là, les aspis qui vivent parmi nous et qui galèrent pour interagir et pour comprendre les neurotypiques,
qui se camouflent à longueur de journée, comment est-ce qu'ils et elles font pour compenser cette souffrance, peut-être parfois...
Est-ce que vous observez peut-être une forme d'arrogance compensatoire de la part des personnes avec autisme ?
Oui.
OK. Est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un peu de ça ?
Je crois qu'effectivement, il y a un peu cette perspective de vivre dans un monde qui les comprend mal. Et je pense qu'il s'agit d'une réaction relativement naturelle.
Finalement, c'est une réaction peut-être de défense par rapport à un vécu qui est difficile et qui est mal compris par un environnement qui peut être un environnement professionnel.
Je pense qu'effectivement,
probablement que l'environnement familial est un environnement plus positif où il y a une recherche de soutenir son conjoint ou
d'avoir du soutien dans un environnement familial, avec difficulté, probablement, hein, pour l'épouse ou pour l'époux, pour le compagnon ou la compagne.
C'est probablement un effort, voilà, permanent que d'essayer de comprendre quelles sont les réactions, pourquoi il réagit de cette façon-là.
Maintenant, dans le milieu professionnel est probablement beaucoup plus difficile à vivre parce que,
bah, il y a une notion de productivité, nécessité de s'adapter à son environnement, d'être socialement sympa, de partager les fêtes entre collègues
et qu'effectivement, lorsqu'on n'a pas nécessairement cette préoccupation-là, hein, qu'on est plutôt attaché à la qualité de son travail et c'est parfois un peu mal vu, hein.
'Fin, disons les choses comme elles sont. Et donc, ça veut dire qu'effectivement, la perspective, c'est d'être sur différents niveaux de valeurs, finalement, hein.
Les valeurs accordées par les uns et par les autres sont pas nécessairement les mêmes.
Et donc, et donc, en réponse à ça...
Bah, je pense qu'il peut y avoir des réactions d'agressivité, parfois, de vraiment mal vivre. Et je crois que moi, je-- c'est peut-être plutôt cet aspect-là que je retiens.
C'est vraiment un mal vivre et d'être finalement assez malheureux de cette situation. Comme le disait Ghislain, c'est un peu de pouvoir apporter des outils et parfois une sensibilisation des employeurs.
C'est une des façons dont, avec lesquelles nous travaillons. Bah évidemment, avec l'accord entier, plein et entier, mais
mais c'est aussi une façon de sensibiliser le monde à l'existence des personnes qui ont un syndrome d'Asperger.
À partir du moment où-- 'fin, nous faisons ces informations dans les écoles, hein, auprès des condisciples, hein.
Quand il y a un enfant, un ado qui a l'autisme, on va parfois donner une information à la classe.
Ça permet qu'effectivement cet enfant soit mieux compris dans ses réactions, mieux accepté par son environnement social et qu'on peut dépasser comme ça et qu'il y a parfois de grandes ressources de solidarité, hein, qui se créent avec
avec ces enfants, ces ados.
Quand on parle d'un milieu adolescent, est-ce que la différence ne devient pas alors un levier pour faire de la stigmatisation ou pour faire du harcèlement ?
Bah, de toute façon, c'est déjà là, hein. C'est plutôt ça le problème, c'est que quand nous intervenons, c'est plutôt parce qu'il y a ces problématiques de harcèlement et ces problématiques.
Et, 'fin, voilà, Joseph Schovanec s'exprime souvent très, très crûment et très, très durement par rapport à son vécu d'enfant et d'adolescent.
Et je pense que c'est malheureusement une réalité pour beaucoup d'entre eux
et que peut-être ces enfants et ces adolescents qu'on voyait moins par le passé dans les services de diagnostic, ces enfants qui ont de bonnes capacités intellectuelles, ont toujours vécu ces situations de,
voilà, de maltraitance pour s'exprimer peut-être un peu simplement sur la question, mais je crois que c'est de tout temps, mais peut-être qu'il n'a pas été de tout temps que l'on diagnostique
cette, ce spectre de l'autisme chez un enf-- un ensemble d'enfants, d'adolescents et voire d'adultes à l'heure actuelle qui revendiquent effectivement ce diagnostic.
Un mot à présent sur l'autisme chez les femmes. On sait que les femmes autistes sont apparemment bien meilleures que les hommes pour mimiquer un comportement dit normal et pour se camoufler.
Et du coup, quand on les teste, ben, elles maintiennent le contact oculaire, elles sourient, etc. parce qu'elles savent que c'est ce qui est attendu d'elles, mais pas parce que c'est spontané.
Et j'ai aussi pu lire que les hommes autistes ressentaient de grandes difficultés pour établir et pour gérer les relations amoureuses, alors que c'est beaucoup moins le cas pour les femmes.
Comment est-ce que vous expliquez aujourd'hui cette différence entre hommes et femmes ?
C'est une question assez actuelle, celle que vous évoquez là.
Oui, parce que je pense à certains experts qui ont dit par le passé que l'autisme était le résultat d'une hypermasculinité du cerveau, par exemple.
Tout à fait. Oui, oui, Baron-Cohen a effectivement-
C'est ça.
...développé toute une théorie là-dessus. Mais à partir du moment où vous avez développé, Ghislain, moi, nous avons dû développer des compétences sociales.
Nous avons dû développer des compétences sociales, mais vous aussi, le commun des mortels doit développer des compétences sociales.
À partir du moment où vous avez dû développer des compétences sociales qui vous permettent de masquer, comme vous l'avez très bien exprimé,
parfois vos émotions, vous êtes confronté à quelqu'un qui vous ennuie profondément, mais vous gardez le sourire.
Je pense qu'à un moment donné, soit on a suffisamment de compétences sociales qui vous font être dans la norme. À ce moment-là, vous n'avez pas un trouble du spectre de l'autisme.
Si les femmes ont plus de capacité que les hommes à développer des compétences sociales pour les sortir du spectre de l'autisme, grand bien, grand bien pour elles.
Je pense qu'à un moment donné, ce diagnostic, il est complexe. Et donc peut-être la première chose à dire, c'est quand même un diagnostic qui n'est pas facile à poser.
Il ne faut pas penser que parce qu'il y a une description dans un manuel machin, que cliniquement, pour les situations individuelles que nous rencontrons, c'est facile à poser.
Surtout quand effectivement, il y a de bonnes compétences sociales, il y a de bonnes compétences communicationnelles et il y a un bon potentiel intellectuel.
Le diagnostic différentiel, il est très complexe chez ces personnes. Parce que qu'est-ce qui est de l'ordre d'une facette pathologique ou qu'est-ce qui est de l'ordre de la normalité ?
Enfin, vous savez, le jour où on pourra faire une prise de sang
à quelqu'un et dire : voilà, il y a de l'autisme parce que dans la prise de sang, il y a telle problématique ou telle problématique génétique ou on fera,
enfin, on fera une imagerie cérébrale et on montrera que systématiquement chez les personnes qui ont l'autisme, cette problématique-là est présente, ce sera beaucoup plus facile pour tout un chacun.
Mais donc on a presque l'impression que vous dites, finalement, aujourd'hui, certains sont en capacité de masquer leurs différences et qu'à ce moment-là,
vous, les cliniciens, ça vous concerne presque beaucoup moins, et qu'elles sont, ces personnes-là sont moins en besoin d'assistance et que-
Si elles ont des besoins d'assistance, c'est une question très différente hein. La question du besoin, elle est différente de la question du diagnostic.
Vous avez des gens qui ont un diagnostic d'un autisme et qui ont de grands besoins, mais les grands besoins, ils sont liés à l'environnement.
Enfin, vous avez de l'autisme dans la province de Luxembourg. Je suis désolé, c'est pas du tout la même situation qu'avoir de l'autisme à Bruxelles ou d'avoir de l'autisme dans une ville wallonne, parce que là-bas, vous n'avez pas les mêmes services.
C'est ça, ouais.
Et donc votre situation de handicap, elle ne va pas être pareille.
Si vous avez un environnement familial qui est très riche, très soutenant, vos besoins sont pas du tout les mêmes que si vous avez la même situation diagnostique d'autisme, mais dans un environnement familial qui est-
J'ai juste du mal à faire la connexion avec la question qui était donc l'autisme chez les femmes.
À partir du moment où vos systèmes de compensation et d'apprentissage, ou votre système
sexuel, si je peux m'exprimer comme ça, c'est-à-dire votre sexe, engendrent le fait que vous avez moins de difficultés sociales et communicationnelles et que ces difficultés sociales et communicationnelles ne sont pas perceptibles.
Problème résolu, vous avez envie de dire.
Non, mais le diagnostic, il sera effectivement difficile à poser. Le jour où l'autisme sera diagnostiqué par une prise de sang indépendante de vos apprentissages et de vos capacités,
ben on aura un diagnostic qui sera formalisé, mais ça ne dira pas quelle est la situation de handicap de la personne ni l'intensité de son problème. Ça, c'est clair.
Ok, donc il y a une distinction importante à faire entre le ressenti d'une part, les difficultés que la personne peut ressentir et d'autre part, la facilité qu'un clinicien peut avoir à détecter, à diagnostiquer.
Techniquement, ça veut dire qu'une personne qui va se présenter auprès de nous avec un
excellent contact visuel, qui aura des difficultés à nous décrire les difficultés qu'elle vit au quotidien au travers de cette problématique d'autisme.
J'ajouterai aussi peut-être qu'une des facettes du diagnostic de l'autisme, c'est la présence des difficultés dans la tendre enfance
et que ça, c'est parfois, quand on fait le diagnostic chez l'adulte, une grande difficulté d'accès à cette information-là.
Si effectivement, on ne peut pas connaître quel a été le développement précoce de la personne, techniquement, on est dans l'incapacité de poser un diagnostic chez l'adulte.
C'est clair, parce que ben voilà, des difficultés relationnelles, tout le monde peut en avoir, mais tout ça ne porte pas les-
Mais je remarque que votre réponse porte plutôt sur la difficulté du diagnostic et pas tellement sur la spécificité.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que chez les femmes, c'est plus compliqué que chez les hommes ?
On n'a aucune donnée à l'heure actuelle par rapport à ça. Non, non, c'est des recherches qui sont en cours. Enfin, et voilà, il y a quelques articles qui parlent de ça, mais à l'heure actuelle, on ne peut pas faire--
on ne peut pas instituer comme état de fait que les femmes sont moins bien diagnostiquées que les hommes. Ça, c'est clair.
Ah donc, vous, vous allez même une étape avant ça, vous dites : si ça se trouve-
Il n'y en a pas autant, ça, c'est très clair.
Dans la population qui demande ici-
Non, ça, c'est clair. Chez nous, depuis trente ans, enfin, vous l'avez évoqué, le pourcentage garçon-fille ne varie pas d'un pour cent.
Mais est-ce que c'est parce que les femmes avec autisme n'existent pas avec un nombre, une quantité semblable à celle des hommes ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'est parce qu'elles n'ont pas les difficultés que ressentent les hommes et qu'elles se camouflent beaucoup mieux et que donc elles ne viennent pas ?
Si elles ne viennent pas, nous sommes dans l'incapacité de dire qu'elles existent ou non. Donc, mais dire qu'elles existent
alors qu'on n'a pas la preuve qu'il s'agit d'un diagnostic spécifique, ça, ça me pose un problème parce qu'on semble dire de prendre pour état de fait que l'on ne diagnostique pas suffisamment les femmes.
Ben, j'attends de voir hein, j'attends de voir parce qu'à l'heure actuelle, il n'y a pas nécessairement de réalité à cette situation clinique.
Ce que moi, j'ai pu entendre, ce sont de nombreux témoignages de personnes qui, en consultant, que ce soit un procédé de diagnostic ou bien, entre guillemets, un simple psychologue qui n'est pas spécialisé dans la question de l'autisme.
Ce que moi, j'ai pu entendre, c'est beaucoup de faux négatifs, c'est beaucoup de : Ah non, je ne crois pas que tu aies de l'autisme.
Je pense que tu es simplement
un peu asocial. Ou voilà, enfin des faux négatifs quoi. On écarte parce que la jeune fille regarde dans les yeux, parce qu'elle sourit, parce qu'elle a intégré les conventions sociales que d'habitude, les jeunes garçons autistes n'intègrent pas.
Mais donc, est-ce qu'on a fait la preuve par la suite qu'elles avaient de l'autisme ?
Ce sont des personnes qui, par après, une fois que les procédés de diagnostic ont évolué, ont fini par se faire diagnostiquer, oui.
Question que je voulais vous poser, qui est à la fois très simple et très compliquée. D'où est-ce que ça vient, l'autisme ?
Est-ce que c'est un facteur génétique ou un facteur environnemental ? Où est-ce qu'on en est ?
On dit que c'est les deux, mais on ne va pas beaucoup plus loin.
Donc une liaison alors entre un terrain génétique et des facteurs environnementaux.
Oui, mais on n'en sait pas plus. Je vais dire qu'on sait qu'il y a beaucoup de gènes qui sont impliqués dans des autismes.
Sont-ils tous les mêmes, ces enfants qui ont de l'autisme, si c'est le gène, celui-là ou celui-là ? Et on ne sait pas ce qui fait que les gènes s'expriment de telle ou telle façon.
Et alors on dit : ben c'est l'environnement, mais l'environnement biologique, l'environnement chimique, etc. Enfin, je pense qu'on ne sait pas exactement comment ça interagit entre eux.
Ce n'est pas tout génétique en tout cas.
J'ai lu qu'on avait cru constater ou qu'on soupçonnait une corrélation entre le fait d'avoir une mère plus âgée à l'accouchement et voilà, l'autisme qui apparaîtrait à ce moment-là plus souvent chez l'enfant.
Est-ce que c'est juste ?
Oui, en tout cas, l'HAS a relevé les chiffres. C'est l'âge du père et l'âge de la mère.
Donc l'âge des parents.
Donc le pourcentage augmente par tranche de dix ans. De dix ans d'âge du père ou de la mère. Il y a aussi la prévalence chez les frères et sœurs.
Donc globalement, on est à moins de un pour cent à l'heure actuelle, mais lorsque le premier enfant a de l'autisme, le second, la probabilité monte à quatre pour cent.
Et donc déjà quatre fois plus de chances d'avoir le second enfant qui a de l'autisme si le premier a déjà de l'autisme, si c'est un garçon, mais c'est sept pour cent si le premier est une fille.
Et donc, plus il y a d'enfants dans la famille qui ont de l'autisme, plus la probabilité augmente pour le troisième.
Si les deux premiers ont de l'autisme, a une, malheureusement, une malchance d'avoir de l'autisme encore plus importante.
Ce qui renforce l'impression que le génétique a une part importante.
Absolument. Et cliniquement, ça, c'est clair que nous rencontrons quand même des familles où il y a plusieurs enfants qui ont soit de l'autisme et pour certains d'entre eux, des troubles de l'apprentissage.
Et en termes techniques, certains parlent de ce qu'on appelle les neurones miroirs. Qu'est-ce que c'est, finalement ?
Ce sont des neurones qui vont s'activer lorsqu'on voit quelqu'un faire la même chose que vous. Donc, si vous voyez quelqu'un qui mange, vos neurones qui sont liés à l'action de manger s'activent.
D'accord.
Sans que vous ne soyez occupé à manger.
On se transpose automatiquement alors-
Ça explique un peu les comportements de bâillement ou ce type de comportements-là. Donc, effectivement, on semble dire que ce serait déficitaire chez les personnes qui ont l'autisme.
Mais ça veut dire que quand une personne avec autisme voit une autre personne bailler, elle ne bâille pas ?
Je vous laisserai monter un plan de recherche, ça nous intéressera et voilà.
Ok.
Venez nous voir.
C'était plutôt pour la blague, mais donc oui. Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on soupçonne ou est-ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on sait ?
Où est-ce qu'on en est par rapport à ça ?
Il y a quelques travaux hein, il y a des Italiens qui ont travaillé sur ces questions, mais ça n'a pas été nécessairement reproduit de manière...
Il y a beaucoup de travaux sur la souris ou sur, voilà, les modèles muriens sont très, très courus. Les souris autistes sont très courues dans, pour différentes recherches.
Mais les neurones miroirs, la recherche a été menée avec des singes. Donc ça veut dire que la vérification sur l'être humain est toujours beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on montre sur les modèles animaux, fussent-ils animaux dits autistes.
Peut-être aussi, ce qui peut être intéressant quand même d'ajouter par rapport à toutes ces questions, c'est quand même qu'à l'heure actuelle, bien sûr, voilà, on traite ici de l'autisme,
mais que cet autisme s'intègre maintenant dans une perspective dite des troubles neurodéveloppementaux et que peut-être, ça nous sort un petit peu de nous enfermer dans une,
peut-être dans des termes trop, enfin, trop rigides.
Tout à l'heure, vous avez abordé la
question des femmes, mais peut-être pouvait-on aborder aussi la question des autres troubles neurodéveloppementaux dans lesquels on va aussi observer des caractéristiques qui sont similaires à celles des personnes avec autisme.
Lequel par exemple ?
Le trouble de l'hyperactivité.
C'est ça, OK.
On va observer des caractéristiques qui sont similaires. La problématique de la cohérence centrale, la problématique de la théorie de l'esprit.
Alors qu'auparavant, on semblait dire que ça n'était propre qu'à l'autisme. Ben,
on constate qu'en regardant un petit peu ce qui se passe dans les autres troubles neurodéveloppementaux, on commence à constater que finalement, en étudiant ça chez les autres, ben, on constate que
ce n'est peut-être pas de la même intensité.
Peut-être qu'on va avoir des profils qui vont se diversifier en fonction des problématiques neurodéveloppementales, mais quand même que peut-être, à force de s'être focalisé sur une problématique, on a exclu
les ponts qui pouvaient exister dans les-
Donc plus on en apprend sur le trouble du spectre de l'autisme, plus on se rend compte que le cerveau, c'est quand même compliqué.
Ah ça, si.
Je pense que ça, c'est peut-être la plus grande leçon que l'on apprenne. Et je pense que l'autisme est probablement
un acteur extrêmement important dans ce secteur de la recherche sur la cognition, sur le développement du cerveau.
Je crois que là, 'fin l'autisme a beaucoup servi et a beaucoup servi aussi en termes d'intervention hein. Les modèles d'intervention aident aussi beaucoup d'autres personnes que les personnes avec autisme.
Et ça, je pense que c'est intéressant aussi, peut-être à noter, c'est que l'autisme a une mission.
Peut-être a été très tardif dans sa prise en charge, mais peut-être que toutes les avancées qui ont lieu dans le domaine de l'autisme servent aussi à d'autres personnes.
Et ça, je crois que c'est socialement très intéressant.
Est-ce que-
Mais d'ailleurs, il faudrait s'interroger. Pourquoi parle-t-on tellement d'autisme ? Et on ne parle quasi jamais, je parle de la Belgique, de la déficience intellectuelle. On n'en parle pas.
Oui, je vous crois sur parole.
Ben non, on n'en parle pas.
Ben très peu en tout cas.
On ne réclame rien, on ne demande rien, alors qu'ils ont aussi des besoins au moins aussi importants que ceux qui ont de l'autisme.
On peut en parler. Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, en Belgique, les médecins, les psychiatres, les enseignants, les psychologues sont formés correctement vis-à-vis de ces questions-là, que ce soit pour l'autisme ou pour
la déficience intellectuelle ?
Où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui dans le paysage des formations en Belgique ? Parce que moi, j'avais pu, par exemple, entendre que, alors évidemment, c'est en France, ce n'est pas en Belgique, mais
que l'autisme était très rapidement évoqué dans les formations de médecins.
Ça reste le cas.
Ça reste le cas ? En Belgique aussi ?
Oui, oui. Maintenant, on ne va pas donner le nombre d'heures de chacune des spécialités, mais même dans les spécialités les plus concernées, en neuropédiatrie ou en pédopsychiatrie, c'est très très peu d'heures.
Ça se compte sur les doigts d'une main.
Comment ça s'explique ça ? Alors que-
Mais c'est le même problème pour les autres troubles neurodéveloppementaux. Et à nouveau, c'est, je pense, c'est une problématique plus globale qu'il faut évoquer plutôt qu'une spécificité liée à l'autisme.
Oui, tout à fait oui.
Et donc, je crois que c'est plutôt là-dessus que les choses se font. Maintenant, ben, on peut, voilà, souligner quand même l'effort qui a été fait par les diverses universités francophones qui ont monté un certificat
hein, dans les troubles du spectre de l'autisme.
Ce certificat est organisé par toutes les universités francophones : l'ULB, l'UCL, l'UMons, l'UNamur, l'ULiège. Et donc ces cours se donnent sur toute une année.
Et donc voilà, c'est un cursus quand même relativement exigeant,
qui permet à des professionnels qui ont un master, donc des médecins, des psychologues, aussi d'autres fonctions qui ont des qualifications de master, mais aussi des personnes qui ont un bachelier,
qui peuvent, grâce à la valorisation de l'expérience professionnelle,
participer à ce-
D'accord. Et ça date de quand ?
On entame la deuxième promotion cette année-ci.
D'accord.
C'est récent hein.
Mais avant, il y en avait un ici à Mons.
Avant, il y en avait un ici à Mons, mais voilà, ces dernières années, on a plutôt milité pour qu'il y ait un, voilà un consensus des universités.
Maintenant, dans les cours de master, il n'y a pas de cours spécifique à l'autisme.
Donc, les médecins restent très peu informés, mais s'ils veulent, ils peuvent suivre ce cursus et se spécialiser.
Alors peut-être aussi, on a conduit, enfin ça continue d'ailleurs à être développé ici, un projet qui s'appelle Starter
et qui vise à l'information des pédiatres et des consultations de l'ONE aux signes très précoces d'un dysfonctionnement communicationnel et social chez les très jeunes enfants.
Et donc ce sont des formations qui sont dédiées aux pédiatres ou dédiées aux généralistes qui travaillent dans les consultations ONE pour qu'ils soient à l'écoute des plaintes des parents.
Ça, c'est pour les médecins, peut-être les psychiatres, peut-être les pédiatres, les personnes qui travaillent avec les jeunes enfants.
Quand on parle des enseignants, quand on parle de l'école, est-ce que les professeurs sont formés pour reconnaître les spécificités de l'autisme ?
Comment enseigner à un enfant avec autisme ?
Au sortir de leur formation ? Non.
Ou s'il y a éventuellement, ce que vous disiez, une spécialisation.
Mais à l'heure actuelle, ils ne sont formés à rien. Je veux dire, au sortir de l'école, ils ne sont formés à aucune prise en charge.
Et l'espoir, c'est qu'avec le pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence, où on parle très timidement, très timidement d'une école inclusive,
j'espère qu'on va former les futurs enseignants aux pédagogies pour avoir une vraie école inclusive.
Donc, c'est un vœu, j'espère qu'il n'est pas que pieux, mais j'espère qu'on va l'imposer dès la première année de la haute école de formation des enseignants.
Mais ce sont des classes à part.
Absolument. Sauf qu'il y a déjà un peu la formation de suivi.
Oui. Alors là, en termes de formation permanente, les enseignants disposent à l'heure actuelle de programmes de formation qui sont délivrés par l'IFC ou par leur réseau, qui sont spécifiquement dédiés à l'autisme.
Et des programmes parfois relativement lourds, de six jours par an.
Et c'est optionnel ou c'est imposé ?
Ah non, ça, c'est optionnel. Donc c'est l'école ou l'enseignant qui, voilà, souhaite participer. Mais ces formations sont pleines chaque année, hein.
Donc, dans les formations approfondies, on forme soixante enseignants par an. Alors c'est beaucoup et c'est pas beaucoup hein,
mais il y a d'autres formations moins ambitieuses qui sont délivrées aussi en termes de nombre de jours, qui sont des formations plus de sensibilisation.
Ici, il y a un programme qui va se développer dans le cadre de la politique d'inclusion à la formation des enseignants, hein, des enseignants de l'enseignement ordinaire.
Et je crois, comme le disait Ghislain là maintenant, c'est que si on veut vraiment l'inclusion, ben ce sera la formation des enseignants qui sera la clé de l'inclusion hein.
Accueillir un enfant qui présente des particularités qui s'appellent l'autisme ou qui s'appellent autre chose nécessite effectivement que ces enseignants aient des outils.
Donc que ce soit pour les médecins, pour les psychiatres, pour les enseignants,
vous dites que la formation de base n'en parle presque pas, mais que par contre, tout le monde a l'option de suivre des formations spécialisées sur ce sujet-là s'ils le veulent.
Je vais peut-être juste insister sur la formation des psychiatres. À l'heure actuelle, je pense que peut-être
les médecins de l'enfance, toutes disciplines peut-être confondues, sont peut-être plus sensibilisés aux problématiques développementales.
Mais à l'heure actuelle, il y a un manque, mais criant, de psychiatres qui s'intéressent à ce type de diagnostic. Nous, ici, nous attendons à pouvoir travailler avec un psychiatre dans notre service de diagnostic parce que,
enfin, vous posiez la question du diagnostic de l'autisme, c'est une chose.
Pouvoir dire que quelqu'un a de l'autisme, c'est une chose. Mais lorsque cette personne ne présente pas de l'autisme, elle a probablement d'autres difficultés.
Mais ici, nous sommes un service plutôt de troisième ligne, en fait hein. Nous ne sommes pas un service de première ligne.
Donc c'est binaire quoi. Vous savez dire si c'est oui ou si c'est non, mais vous ne savez pas dire si c'est autre chose.
C'est très clair qu'il y a des diagnostics différentiels qui ne sont pas accessibles à notre capacité et que nous ne devrions pas devoir faire.
Or, ben le problème, c'est la problématique des services de première ligne et de seconde ligne qui ne jouent pas à l'heure actuelle hein.
On reçoit ici, je vais dire, le tout-venant hein, des gens qui téléphonent en disant : Voilà, je veux vous voir parce que j'ai une suspicion d'autisme.
Je voudrais que vous voyiez ma situation.
Alors qu'idéalement, ça devrait être, si pas chez le médecin généraliste-
Oui, non, évidemment, mais probablement, effectivement hein, que la consultation d'un spécialiste permettrait quand même, voilà, d'éliminer toute une série de situations.
On a le sentiment que poser sur un patient le diagnostic de, voilà, trouble du spectre de l'autisme, c'est, vous disiez, les psychiatres sont en général assez peu informés sur l'autisme.
On a l'impression que poser ce diagnostic, c'est effrayant pour beaucoup de psys. On a l'impression qu'ils ont le sentiment que c'est enfermer le patient dans une cage et que, voilà, c'est un petit peu leur bête noire.
Est-ce que c'est votre expérience ?
Je pense que que quelqu'un soit éclairé sur sa propre condition personnelle l'ouvre sur un champ de possibilités, non ? Si effectivement quelqu'un n'a pas d'information sur sa problématique, sur ce qu'il vit, je pense que ça l'enferme.
Et donc on est plutôt dans une perspective inverse. Mais je comprends, et c'est la situation que vivent beaucoup de parents lorsqu'ils consultent leur pédiatre ou leur médecin, lorsque l'enfant
présente des difficultés, c'est qu'il y a une grande hésitation à évoquer cette problématique d'un problème, voilà.
Et je pense qu'il s'agit peut-être dans l'esprit de certains de peut-être rassurer les gens, alors que je crois que ça les rassure pas du tout.
C'est que finalement-
Ils cherchent des réponses.
Ils cherchent des réponses et c'est arrivé quelques années plus tard dans des services comme le nôtre ou d'autres services de collègues où effectivement, ils viennent avec
cette perspective où c'est quand même pas la première fois qu'on parle de nos problèmes, mais on nous a jamais entendu, on n'a jamais eu de réponse par rapport à nos difficultés.
Alors que ça s'appelle de l'autisme ou autre chose, c'est une autre question. Mais enfin, nous sommes, enfin, d'emblée, on a été preneurs avec l'idée qu'il fallait dire aux parents et dire aux personnes les problèmes dont ils souffrent.
Je crois que c'est par la bonne information que quelqu'un peut se prendre en charge lui-même ou aider quelqu'un d'autre à évoluer dans...
Alors, il va bientôt être l'heure de se quitter. Le SUSA, on disait, a bientôt trente ans.
En guise de conclusion, j'aurais voulu vous demander à chacun de sélectionner une grande avancée dont vous rêvez peut-être pour les trente prochaines années en ce qui concerne l'autisme.
Voilà, si vous deviez en sélectionner une chacun, peut-être en commençant par Ghislain Magerotte.
Ben moi, ce que je dirais, c'est qu'on s'est beaucoup focalisé sur les tout-petits, sur l'éducation des tout-petits, mais qu'en même temps, on a oublié les grands, les adultes.
Les adultes.
Et donc, or, en fait, les grands, les adultes sont plus nombreux que les petits. Et donc mon espoir, c'est que ce que l'on a fait pour les petits, on le fasse aussi pour les adultes.
Ça, c'est votre espoir, peut-être pour les trente prochaines années.
Oh, j'espère que ça se réalisera avant, mais je pense qu'effectivement, on a mis beaucoup le paquet sur les méthodes d'intervention.
Très bien. Donc ça, c'est votre rêve pour le futur, Ghislain Magerotte.
Oui.
Eric Willaye, quelle est votre sélection ?
Alors, c'est un vaste projet, ça, parce qu'il y a encore beaucoup, beaucoup de choses à faire. Mais, ceci dit, je pense que
pour moi, l'évolution quand même de ces trente dernières années, c'est que l'autisme est devenu une réalité sociale, alors que
par le passé, enfin, on parle d'une autre époque hein, mais c'est vrai qu'au démarrage des activités du SUSA hein, l'autisme était quelque chose, je vais dire, d'un peu anecdotique. D'un peu...
Voilà, il y en avait. D'accord, mais est-ce que c'était si important que ça ? Je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle, la médiatisation, la meilleure connaissance qu'on a de cette problématique fait aussi que c'est devenu une réalité.
Une réalité qui, malheureusement, est devenue, en termes de prévalence, relativement importante hein, quatre à cinq pour dix mille au début des années nonante.
Maintenant, on est à quasi un pour cent. Ça veut dire que cette réalité, elle est plus qu-- 'fin, elle est aussi en termes de chiffres et de données.
Alors, je crois que la-- 'fin, ce qui nous...
'fin, l'espoir qu'on doit avoir pour ces prochaines années, c'est que ce que l'on va pouvoir faire peut-être avec les familles de manière plus précoce et avec les professionnels qui s'occupent de la jeune enfance permette à
la majorité des personnes qui ont de l'autisme de trouver une place dans notre société.
Alors la question, ce sera de savoir quelle place, pour quoi y faire, etc. Mais qui est cette place qui leur soit réservée, pas réservée en termes de vivre
entre autistes, mais réservée au sens d'avoir une réelle place parmi les autres.
Et je crois que ça, ça nécessitera pas seulement un effort des personnes qui ont de l'autisme à vivre dans notre société hein, mais que notre société s'ouvre à la différence.
Et voilà, je pense que Ghislain l'a très bien dit tout à l'heure, c'est vivre avec la différence dès son plus jeune âge qui nous amènera à ce que tous puissent avoir une place, c'est-à-dire que nous, en tant que personnes ordinaires,
soyons confrontés à la différence dès notre jeune enfance hein.
C'est l'immersion quasi en sens inverse qu'il faudrait imaginer hein. C'est que nous côtoyons dans notre vie de tous les jours des-- 'fin, lorsqu'on est enfant, ben qu'on côtoie d'autres enfants qui ont des handicaps.
Et je crois que le challenge, c'est ce challenge-là, l'inclusion. L'inclusion, c'est pas d'avoir une scolarité ordinaire pour avoir un diplôme.
C'est aussi bien sûr ça, mais c'est aussi avoir une scolarité ordinaire pour vivre avec ceux qui ont le même environnement communautaire.
J'ajouterais juste une petite chose. Je pense qu'il faut que les services soient plus family friendly. C'est-à-dire qu'il faut se focaliser sur l'enfant dans sa famille.
Mais quand il deviendra adulte, il ne va pas vivre dans une famille parce qu'il va perdre ses parents, probablement, mais qu'il ait un style de vie qui se rapproche un petit peu d'une forme de vie commune, communautaire, un peu familiale.
Je pense que c'est quand même important.
Très bien. Et donc, une approche plus family friendly, une place plus importante pour les personnes avec autisme dans notre société, y compris pour les adultes.
Tout à fait.
Ce sont deux messages d'espoir, voilà, pour conclure cette émission. Ghislain Magerotte, Eric Willaye, merci beaucoup-
Merci à vous.
..d'avoir passé Septante Minutes Avec Moi. Et, voilà, on se dit à dans deux semaines. Au revoir. Et c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode.
Je vous avais promis des recommandations. Alors, en premier, le documentaire français qui s'appelle Syndrome d'Asperger : dans la peau d'un extraterrestre, que j'ai beaucoup aimé.
C'est fait par deux filles, une journaliste et une artiste aspi.
Et, dans ce documentaire, elles rencontrent, entre autres, une série d'autistes Asperger, dont une femme qui s'appelle Julie Dachez, qui est docteure en psychologie et autiste Asperger, qui est
parfaitement géniale et qui a publié un bouquin sur le sujet, qui est ma deuxième recommandation, qui s'appelle : Dans ta bulle, les autistes ont la parole, écoutons-les.
Et c'est super. Donc je vous recommande tout ça et je vous mets tous les liens dans la description. Enfin, avant de se quitter, je voulais juste faire le point sur deux, trois aspects.
Ghislain Magerotte et Eric Willaye ont été parfaitement charmants et parfaitement généreux de me recevoir. Ils ont aussi été très catégoriques sur certains points, notamment sur le vocabulaire et sur les femmes.
Alors, dans cette démarche journalistique qui est la mienne, c'est essentiel d'avoir leur point de vue. Ils sont experts en la matière et ça se voit.
Cela dit, je trouvais important de mettre quelques bémols. Premièrement, tout le monde ne partage pas leur opinion pour ce qui est des femmes qui sont autistes Asperger.
Vous l'avez entendu, Eric Willaye est assez sceptique quant à leur différence vis-à-vis des hommes. Il existe, à côté de ça, d'autres experts qui défendent une position opposée.
Voilà. Deuxièmement, je pense que Ghislain Magerotte a été très clair à ce niveau-là. Il n'aime vraiment pas qu'on dise être autiste.
Il préfère qu'on dise avoir de l'autisme. Il estime que ça ne définit pas une personne. Mais pour le coup, je dois dire que je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui et qu'à mon sens, avoir de l'autisme, ça définit en grande partie qui on est.
Voilà, c'était les deux petites précisions que je trouvais importantes de faire. Et enfin, plus léger, on blaguait en cours d'interview sur les personnes autistes qui ne bâillent pas quand on bâille devant elles.
En fait, il y a vraiment eu plusieurs études qui montrent que les enfants autistes bâillent moins que les autres quand ils voient bâiller quelqu'un.
Je me disais bien que c'était pas quelque chose qui m'arrivait souvent. Allez, à dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode avec Jérôme Colin de la RTBF. Salut !